[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
the chat wants to know if I'm going to
talk about Donald Trump's drained speech
and this little dick energy oh excuse me
little crowd energy ah he's already
posting this morning on fraud social
about how big his crowds were which only
indicates how small he knew they were
how Smalls they were like mushroom size
that [__]
retribution really
Revenge vengeance
listen
folks
Ron DeSantis was not at CPAC
because he's not welcome at CPAC
the reason why Rhonda santis
De Santos DeSantis whatever whatever
however you want to say it I like the
Santos by the way
the reason why meatball Ron
has no [__] chance is because grandpa
is all in on the Hitler he's all in on
it 100 percent
All In
he's gonna out Hitler Rhonda Santos 100
percent
that meatball doesn't have to have a
chance not a [__] prayer
against this man who will absolutely say
anything
he will say
to win the nomination
in the Republican Party
that not doesn't give two [__]
he's not going to run as an independent
uh he's he's going to absolutely
obliterate Nikki Haley already has Nikki
Haley's done she might as well just stop
now there's a video out
I said hey Nikki
you're not you're not cold and
calculated fascist enough
and it's clear that you're trying to do
the old oh let's get back to the normal
Republican party there it's gone
it's gone it doesn't exist
if you think that the Republican Party
pre-trump exists anymore you were not
paying attention over the weekend
you're just not paying attention
and for Rhonda santis to be on the side
of Paul Ryan here because that's where
he's at
it's where he's at
Ron DeSantis does not have an entry into
this race at all
not that I can see
what what could what could Ron DeSantis
possibly do now I know a lot of people
in the media are going oh but I heard
this this morning Rhonda santis is a
governor of the state of Florida and he
can Institute his ideas
and convince the masses that that's what
should happen with America
Rhonda santis isn't doing [__] in
Florida besides giving us the exact
reasons why no one would want that
[__] to be president of all the
states
Trump gets to stand and say anything he
wants he doesn't have to be held
accountable to anything he says
he does he doesn't have to have any kind
of facts or any kind of real substance
behind it he can literally just say yes
if you were wronged by your political
enemies I am your retribution we will go
after them he means People Like Us
people who think like us
who have ideas like us
who want Liberty and freedom because
they don't
they want the liberty and freedom I mean
Michael Knowles was on stage saying it
they want the liberty and freedom to
eradicate groups of people I don't give
a [__] if it has ISM at the end of it
he wants to eradicate people
if you're not catching on
that they're using little language
to make sure that the Rolling Stone
changes their headline
you're not paying attention they're
fascist they will load you on trains
folks I said last year I told you last
year during the summer during the lead
up to the midterms that these people
were gonna use transgender children to
strip away your parental consent and
that is what the [__] they're doing in
Tennessee
they want to take parental consent away
they do not want parents
to have consent of their children they
want the fascist government to tell you
and your children what the [__] you're
gonna do what the [__] you're gonna
learn who you're gonna be
doubt me on this you [__] doubt
me I'm telling you I'm telling you right
now
clear and concise
these people are [__] Nazis
and if we if we allow them to continue
to hold power in our gut because we
can't get rid of an idea I've been
telling you this you can't get rid of an
idea it's not a [__] thing you're not
gonna eradicate an idea
that's why that's why what Michael moles
is saying is ridiculous
eradicating an idea is not a thing it
just is not once the idea is it is
and forever we want to stand around and
be offended by an idea and not do
something about it
it's like it's like people on the
internet yeah I'm talking to you lefties
offended that Joe Biden is going to be
the nominee and me saying it out loud
telling you the [__] truth and what's
gonna happen is somehow me being a cult
member and a Biden sympathizer or some
[__] get the [__] over it just because
you don't like the truth doesn't mean
that you you get to [__]
melt some [__] alternate reality
listen Joe Biden is not going to have a
challenger what don't you understand
media what don't you understand your
little Twitter accounts I'm talking to
you on the left
oh well you must be an occult Tony
because you know that Joe Biden's gonna
be the nominee how does that make me an
occult you stupid bastards listen here's
the thing here's the thing
it doesn't matter
what the truth is with some folks
they are always going to believe what
they want to believe and that is the
difference between belief and opinion
yes opinions can be belief
beliefs are not always opinion they're
not
if your belief is is that is is that
this
that there's oh well we should have a
different nominee of the Democratic
National
party
and Joe Biden's just too old he's not
too old where does it say he's too old
where are you getting this garbage
because you don't like that the way he
walks the way he talks or how he looks
are you [__] serious
listen to me when I tell you this
there is no use of Marianne Williamson
going on and sympathizing with a bunch
of conservatives in Fox News
Gavin Newsom in the governor of
California is not going to mount a
campaign against Joe Biden's record he
won't
he's not gonna do it Gavin Newsom isn't
that [__] stupid
nor is anyone else in the Democratic
party thinking that they're going to go
into primaries with the record that Joe
Biden has listen you are forgetting what
election we are in
this has nothing to do with the general
election of 2024. right now the election
cycle is the Republican primary
the Republican primary that is the
election cycle who gives a rats flying
ass what Marianne Williamson is going to
do who gives a [__]
only the clout Chaser Marianne
Williamson gives a [__]
the race that is before us
to make sure that we make the narrative
and spend
the national truth is the Republican
primary folks there is not going to be a
race in the Democratic departy there's
just not you can say whatever you want
you can opine you can hope you can dream
but it's all [__] there's only one
race in front of us
and it's to make sure that the
Republican Party owned their nominee
full stop
full stop own their [__] nominee
because I don't know if you ever pay
attention over the weekend
Donald Trump is the front runner here
folks he's gonna [__] win and nothing
excites me more than the absolute
[__] impotence that was at CPAC
the worst one yet
he's got a hold on Association in this
country and he will win in these
primaries
he will [__] win
because people are not going
to clap back on the Maga cult they're
just not gonna do it
I mean Pompeo tried over the weekend
Pompeo good luck
I don't know if you noticed in right
wing talk but that his little narrative
about and they're doing they're trying
to do the old thin veiled conservatism
to hide their fascism you remember this
this is the [__] they've been doing
since the 19 late 70s
oh we're conservative we're conservative
we want lower taxes we want less
government I mean unless it has to do
with your vagina
unless it has to do with your children
and their con and your consent of them
unless it has to do with what the [__]
you're gonna wear during a performance
and what songs you're gonna sing
what music You're Gonna Play [__]
they're trying to ban dancing you dumb
[__]
conservatism in this country has always
been thin veiled fascism give me a
[__] break and people people out
there that are whining and complaining
that oh I've been I'm a never Trumper
George Conway Rick Wilson Steve Schmidt
yeah I'm calling you out on the mat you
[__] have always been for thin
veil fascism
called conservatism you caused this [__]
and I'm glad that some of you are
standing up to fight against it now but
don't act like you didn't do this to our
[__] country
the man stood on stage in front of tens
of people
and he's gonna be the nominee think
about it
think about where we're at
and why it is so important for you to
engage in your democracy today not next
year not next cycle not after he's
indicted now right now and to continue
to do it
I watched a a great clip of Eric
swalwell and he had a great quote
because everyone's like oh you can't
fight fire with fire
I mean you can
foreign
but he had he he said the most amazing
thing
we have to play on their side of the
field
or we will lose the game
we have to we cannot stop
we cannot let up
it is so important and I'm I'm gonna
show you today the crazy deranged [__]
that the Cheeto dust q and honor said
into a microphone oh it's the same old
I'm a victim [__]
they're coming after me because I
committed crime
the [__] out of here
but he went steps further over the
weekend
promising retribution
of his political enemies
and it's hilarious it's laughable to be
quite honest because this people he's
speaking to
is the people he incited to go commit
violence at the United States capital
overturned the government in his honor
and now they're all in jail and indicted
in federal charges and a lot of them are
waiting to be based on the state elector
scheme
members of Congress members of his
administration waiting to be indicted by
Jack Smith
he could have pardoned all these people
he could have done that
he didn't
and he's mad he's mad that we [__]
rejected him
and that's what it's about his Vengeance
on us
the 80 million people who voted against
that [__]
who said nope sorry [__] and then in
2022 told them the exact same thing nope
sorry [__]
it's a no-go for me on the fascism thing
not gonna happen
the only reason why Kevin McCarthy is
the speaker now is because they
gerrymander the [__] out of districts in
red States and in blue States and we let
them get away with it
we We the People let them get away with
this [__]
we again Eric swallow said this more we
have to play on their side of the field
you goddamn right I believe that
Democrats in blue States state
legislators right now state blue State
Governors should be saying if we wanted
to have a have a national divorce well
let's let's [__] serve them their
papers then [__] let's serve
the [__] divorce papers let me tell
you something we're going to gerrymander
the ever-loving [__] out of blue States
we're gonna we're gonna gerrymander
Republicans
out of existence in red States yeah
what's what we should do [__] you
so what we should do
you want to get them to stop to stop
doing that [__] show them that we will
do it and we will do it better
listen the day
the day that Mark Elias has to file a
lawsuit against Democrats is the day
we're winning that battle folks
did you follow what I just [__] said
the day that Mark Elias has to file
[__] lawsuits against Democrats
because they're gerrymandering is the
day we win that battle
can you imagine can you imagine
Republicans being on the side of Mark
Elias
we win
oh but Tony you steeped her there you
stooped to their level
just playing on their side of the field
I am unwilling to give away my democracy
for my children my grandchildren and
future Generations I'm unwilling to do
it
not gonna do it
and I think everyone out there in the
pro-democracy Coalition should be
unwilling as well
and if you're not paying attention to
how they're systematically using our
democracy to destroy it then you're not
paying attention to what's happening in
Tennessee you're not paying attention
what's happening Texas and you're
definitely not paying attention to what
the [__] is happening in Florida
yeah
you need to pay the [__] attention and
not only do you need to pay attention
you need to get other [__] to
pay attention
yell and scream and wave your hands
and if it means that we have to go to
war inside these states and gerrymander
these districts
to get these Republicans to understand
that we will fight for our democracy
you do what you want to do [__]
but we will fight with politics
and we will fight with elections
at every single turn at every single
pass
we will fight for our democracy by
politicizing any issue that comes our
way
that's right I said it I'm the only one
that will [__] say it
why am I the only one that will say it
well I'll be damned if I'm not going to
get other people to follow and saying it
this idea that somehow because of the
truth
because of the truth
that the the two nominees are gonna be
Joe Biden
and Donald Trump somehow I'm mired in
delusion and occult
you are not paying attention
just because you want something and you
tweet about it doesn't mean it's gonna
happen
stop it
fight with your democracy fight with it
that's what you do that's why I call out
David packman tyt
oh tyt I I almost I almost bit
right now I I can't say for sure because
I don't watch that [__] garbage but I
almost bet I almost BET right now
Marianne Williamson is getting her mic
fitted on her for a tyt interview almost
bet and she's gonna go on and talk about
how both sides are the same
that she's gonna say both sides are the
same oh my God I get all kinds of hate
from the righties and I get all kinds of
hate from the lefties it's called life
dumbass you're running in an election
you [__] idiot
what did Marianne Williamson think she
was going to do run for prison in every
single Democrat and every single leftist
every single person who voted for Joe
Biden regardless of why most of them
voted against Trump for for biting
against Trump they were just gonna go oh
you know what that's right I [__] that
Marion Williamson that's who we're
behind you are a dumb you are a dumb
[__]
Marianne Williamson and I almost BET
right now she's being fitted for her
microphone on tyt to talk about how both
sides are the same and this weekend
there was a contrast I did a video on my
patreon yet last night the Sunday rant
uh it's getting very popular this Sunday
rant over on patreon if you want to
check it out to go to patreon.com the
Tony Michaels or go to
thetonymichaels.com and check out our
patreon I did a q a on Saturday and we
did the Sunday rant yesterday but the
Sunday rant was about this the contrast
of the weekend
President Joe Biden went down
to the Edmund Pettus bridge in Selma
Alabama
commemorate Bloody Sunday
where 600 activists
black activists walked across a bridge
named after a KKK Grand Dragon got
beaten to the inch of their lives
a congressman that we know well John
Lewis
which they are almost died
almost died for his democracy
and it wasn't drag queens that were
standing in their way
it wasn't books that stood in their way
it was fascist racist bigots
that's what stood in their way
and on the stage at CPAC Michael Knowles
that vile [__] Nazi stood on stage
calling for the eradication of
transgender people I don't give a [__]
what is them he said
that's the contrast
don't give me this [__] boat parties
are the same [__] Marianne Williamson
and when that's the start when that's
the start of your little whatever it is
you think you're gonna run for president
that's what I'm talking about when I say
there is not one not one
viable option that is going
to challenge Joe Biden's record
yeah there's gonna be boneheads running
and acting like they're running
but there's not going to be one not one
serious viable campaign against Biden so
stop talking about it
stop talking about the nonsense the
[__] he's too old he'd been a
government too long he's got four more
years left [__] six
five
whatever
it ain't he ain't got that long left and
then he's done
you're losing sight of what matters most
where the threat of democracy comes from
the threat of democracy does not come
from Joe Biden's birthday
from Joe Biden not being able to
accomplish every single thing that you
wanted only eighty percent of it he only
got eight percent of what we wanted at
[__] scumbag
that's not the threat to democracy pluck
your head out of your ass
you think Hitler won just by his
propaganda
do you think that's how it worked
people didn't speak out and speak up
and it's time we get [__] loud
and I'm only one microphone and I know I
yell and scream I get it
but you have thousands of microphones
thousands of them hundreds of thousands
millions of microphones
that is you
you get loud get proud of your democracy
defend it engage in it and understand
what the threat is it ain't Joe Biden's
birthday
it ain't
and by the way by the way
to call
to call to call someone who who is
a supporter
of democracy rather it's Joe Biden or a
ham sandwich running that democracy the
way he's running it
to call them a cultist is really [__]
funny
because I don't I don't know if anyone
knows this but my rhetoric is very
heated it's very real it's very raw I
don't give a [__] but how many times
this is a question for the honest how
many times have I
[__] pimped for Joe Biden tell me
show me the examples give me the
examples
I I admit I've talked about him a little
bit
a little bit but I know what the threat
is
I know where the threat comes from I
know who wants to destroy our democracy
and it is not Joe Biden
he's given more power and more equity
to the American people
than any other modern president and if
you don't like it
just [__] prove me wrong I don't give
a [__] try it
you're not going to you're not gonna do
it
try it
I dare you
and then show me show me someone who can
mount a campaign against him
and the other thing that you have to
remember
is show me show me a person
who has beat Trump by eight million
[__] votes [__]
show me show me the other person that
has beat Trump by eight million votes
I know after this weekend like before
the weekend I figured the number is
going to be about 14 million
I'm dead serious I think in 2024 Joe
Biden will beat Donald Trump by 14
million before this weekend
I think it's getting close to 15 million
and you say well Tony if he's beating
him by that many boats how will Donald
Trump be the nominee
you're not understanding
how our [__] democracy our two-party
democracy works you just don't get it
you're not understanding
Donald Trump is in a Republican primary
race
he's the only one in it
I mean Nikki Haley but she's done he are
he already ko'd her
he already knocked her out she's done
Mike Pompeo was using the same stupid
[__] old ass thin-bailed conservatism
then bail fascism with conservatism
where will you know the administration
who raised the debt more than anyone was
the one I worked in and the one I
genuflected to
Mike Pompeo get the [__] out of here you
think that guy's gonna be get though he
he is not even gonna come close
if you don't see what's happening
then you got blinders on
your wanting outcomes that don't exist
so get with the program get with the
truth
and watch this [__] show and you'll
get it every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific on YouTube Twitter and twitch do
not forget to smash the Subscribe button
that shit's free it's [__] free to
subscribe on the YouTube channel why
haven't you done it I don't know it's
it's bewildering to me go subscribe to
the YouTube channel it's free hit the
like button share that [__] also follow
us on Twitter at Tony Michaels pod and
download every single episode that's
free 99 five finger discount over on
Apple Spotify Google it's stealing
you're stealing the show when you do
this also visit
patreon.com the Tony Michaels or
tonymichaels.com
to get all the details for the Sunday
Rants and the Q a you can go re-watch
them if you want you can join patreon
and I've done that I don't think I've
done three three or four Sunday rants we
did a q a this weekend it's called ask
me anything
go check them out on patreon.com the
Tony Michaels or you can go to
thetonymichaels.com that's the
tonymichaels.com and support there
all right
we're gonna get into these Trump videos
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
right after these messages
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another
momentum we're back to the Tony Michaels
podcast
oh shitload of cliffs to play over the
weekend
on her in front of tens of people
[Music]
I'm gonna show you a couple videos here
proving how small his crowd actually was
I'm not [__] you
um one of the best moments though
I mean I mean he went on and carried on
and again he played victim oh whoa me I
broke crimes and they're coming after me
they're gonna try to indict me and
prosecute me for committing crime oh man
uh whatever happened to my white
privilege in this country you [__]
slug okay but the the best clip the best
clip
is When Donald Trump is speaking and
someone rolls in on a dolly like a sound
system and starts playing [__] Donald
Trump I'm not kidding you this is
[__] real
um because I'm going to show you two
different clips because it looked like
to me from this clip that I'm going to
show you that it might have been edited
or something uh but no I I think this is
real I think this actually happened I
wasn't there so you know I mean I'm
going based on the evidence that I'm
finding on the internet
um so but uh here is
here's the moment uh where Donald
Trump's speaking and it just so happens
that the song [__] Donald Trump starts
playing let's listen
pervert to use the names of Washington
and Lincoln divide millions of dollars
in ads
to say bad liveless and incorrect things
about us
by the way it's a good song it's a good
song I think it's a good song
I think it is
where the [__] is Gabe Sanchez said I
gotta get his opinion on this and he's
not Ian coming the show yet and I'm not
gonna do the [__] list uh um song
because we just don't have time I got
too many [__] glitch from CPAC to
show today now but this clip here is is
is brilliant of course you see you see
the look on his face he's [__] pissed
that someone's playing the [__] Donald
Trump song
f [__] snowflake [__] ass little
[__]
um and then I found this video because I
was because that video seems like okay
that seems real but it feels like to me
that someone just put the music over
that part of the speech right
I mean it's possible that it was edited
uh with the sound but I found this video
and this is clearly clearly from CPAC
um here is uh you can see it's a like a
sound system here on the dolly and it
pulls it now they're gonna kick this
person out but watch as the camera pans
up at the crowd
and you hear you hear he's talking
Donald Trump is talking at this moment
now look at the crowd I mean
this is kind of you know AB lackluster
really honestly they're not packed in
here like standing he act like they were
standing that there was there was only
standing room and it's not even close to
what was happening I mean maybe maybe
people were laying across the chairs
taking naps or something but um you know
that's how they were filling all the
seats but it wasn't standing room only
but watch watch what happens as security
catches on to this person is playing the
[__] Donald Trump song while Donald
Trump is speaking watch how they kick
him out
and the crowd's really pissed off right
they're really pissed off you see here
you see the crowds really mad now this
is the side and I'll show you um we
might be able to see another photo
somewhere today of this room but they
can't they have a stage in the middle
and there are wings so there's the left
wing right wing and then there's a meat
there's the front row seats and then
there's like a media stage right there
um so they can capture you know all the
fascist networks the trader TVs networks
like a real American Voice news max Ohan
you know Fox wasn't even there
apparently
um Steve Bannon dug into Fox because Fox
wasn't there and he really thinks he got
Rupert Murdoch oh man Rupert Murdock
even Dominion is not going to shut down
Fox News folks Rupert Murdoch has has
more money than he needs to make Fox
News survive this is really dumb to
think that Fox News is is not gonna
exist after this Dominion lawsuit and
somehow Fox News isn't going to exist
because it doesn't go to CPAC you people
are not aware of how right-wing media
works this is really honestly this is
the [__] problem that the left hands
a lot of times is they do not understand
how rhetorical media Works they just
don't get it they don't [__]
understand it they won't understand it
it's a problem that we got
okay it just is it just is a problem
but they just don't get it let's finish
up this clip um watching him get kicked
out here
[Applause]
the crowd was really pissed oh they were
really pissed did you see that they were
super pissed I don't know why it's such
a great song I want you guys think that
it's a great song
why why what
I think it's a great song
I really do
I mean
what else are you looking for in a song
Oh Let's see we got more
um looks like Gabe Sanchez is going to
be joining us here in a second uh let's
see if I can find the thread
I think Aaron Rupert had it of Donald
Trump I hope this sounds halfway decent
there's a lot of other
um
uh oh here
well that's not what I want I was trying
to show you a picture of
of CPAC I think I've got one here
somewhere
uh but there's a lot of other Clips
other than just uh Trump but we're going
to go through some of these Trump Clips
because I want to get through that and
then we're going to do we're going to go
through some of the [__] that's
happening in Tennessee
um as they try to pass the these
anti-drag bills and they're trying to
eradicate transgender people all around
the country just like Michael Knowles
and I'm gonna I'm gonna play that I also
want to go through
how Mike Pompeo is a [__] ass [__]
um and he's gonna he's gonna get Rhonda
Santos just slammed uh let's see there
Ah that's Athens oh oh by the way we're
gonna watch the clip where Donald Trump
um it's obvious that Stormy Daniels
still still lives rent free inside his
little [__] skull so we're gonna
watch that and there it is okay here we
go that's the clip I want I believe uh
let's see which one should I play first
I mean there's a lot of them
hahaha
there's a lot of Clips oh boy let's see
oh boy oh boy
um let's see well I want to play the
retribution clip and I want to wait for
Gabe Sanchez to get here uh in the room
so that uh he can comment on the
retribution because I think he'll
probably have a lot to say on it
um
um and I guess I guess the only part
that is important because here is one of
Aaron's
um
tweets he says Fox News is carrying at
least part of Trump's speech which is
quite rare these days you can see a
screenshot here from Fox News Now where
they were carrying uh just just his
speech I actually didn't report much on
Fox News ah there he is about goddamn
time I mean I'm just saying what the
[__] you're late man wow
wow it is Monday it is Monday it is
Monday it is Monday so we're gonna play
these uh I I played the the clips of the
person who walked in while Donald Trump
was speaking and started blaring the
[__] Donald Trump oh yeah yeah it's one
of the best clips of the whole thing and
I I started with that so you know yeah
the audience could leave at this point
they're like oh that's all right yeah
that was that was it I wish I wish you
could hear the song better
right you know because like you hear it
slightly and then you hear a bunch of
people who are like Boo Boo and they're
like screaming over and stuff I mean
just the fact that it was playing I
don't think he heard it as um as much
because he only hears himself talking
right yeah right but but at some point
when they were booing and stuff and
there was commotion uh then I think he
noticed and he gave that oh yeah he's
like there I think that wasn't that the
same line where he was like uh attacking
Lincoln project and was like they're
paying millions of dollars to come after
me right right now there's a lot of
people playing millions of dollars to
come after you you fool yeah uh let's
see now this is the Aaron rupar um
thread that I'm gonna be pulling these
from the audio is decent on these
um but there's a lot I mean we we can
agree that because he he went on two
nights didn't he he went on Friday no I
don't think so just pretty sure he was
on Friday too oh no man just though yeah
[__] you think that [__]
wouldn't would give two speeches hold on
hold on here we go you want to know how
I'm gonna check this all right I I
literally because I'm I'm doing uh I'm
doing a these are all from March 4th my
friend yeah I know I know that he he he
did a send-off but I'm almost positive
he did two I feel like he did two
speeches hold on no no
I literally have all the footage and I
have it transcribed so I need to search
through it really quick
uh okay even the chat's saying no no no
you got it wrong oh my God he's I
thought he didn't get it wrong my friend
one night Deborah says no one night one
night and what happened the other day
when it was Friday I looked down I don't
know it hits hold on hold on
um Let me let me go look up his Gaylord
Convention Center real quick yes
Saturday yep yeah yep so I thought I
thought I swear I thought
um and someone says you're thinking of
Don Jr
no I saw Don Jr but when I looked down
now here's here's the thing here's the
thing
C-SPAN was like oh yeah Trump gave the
speech you know what was the morning of
Friday morning from Junior no no it was
dropped all right well okay here's here
here's the thing here's here's what I
think is the problem I don't know if you
did a video where you were playing
Donald Trump Jr but I think you might
have snorted a little bit too much
cocaine to get into character and you're
losing track of reality here it's just
it's a thing all right all right hey I
went speaking of cocaine okay I know
this is way off top did you go see it
you goddamn right I wouldn't seen
cocaine bear I was disappointed that Don
Jr wasn't in it I really was but it's a
great [__] movie did you go see it
yet I haven't seen it yet I'm still dude
I'm so behind on stuff I need to see
listen listen here's something I'm still
trying to do my Don Jr [__] uh review
of here's the thing it doesn't matter if
you get
um uh uh spoilers there's nothing that's
gonna spoil this movie it is exactly
what but the cocaine bear that is just
it like that's yeah like that's what it
is ah according to Kalyn she says I am
right but it was a video message oh oh
my god oh damn but he did not give a
speech yeah no no speech no speech okay
just just just some sort of deranged uh
video that Liz Harrington directed under
our suggestions yeah after multiple
takes of like and action he's like I
can't say yesterday yep yet no he was
saying to to Matt to Matt Tamara Tamara
[Music]
so Jeremy London had a funny tweet where
he was like methadone bear just doesn't
have the same ring to it right
yeah oh you're back on the cocaine bear
thing yeah have we left the cocaine bear
Oh I thought we were I we're jumping
back and forth here you know you gotta
you gotta you gotta try to make it
Donald Trump cocaine bear Donald Trump
cocaine Bears all the same [__] thing
really right it really is all he he did
look like he was the Adderall bear on
stage though yeah why not I mean he
tried to pull a Willy Wonka oh wait are
you talking about Trump or Don Jr I mean
either but yeah but but no well I mean
definitely Trump Jr oh booger sugar
Junior yeah yeah was doing some coke I
mean but but I mean I don't know if
Donald Trump does Coke but he definitely
does Adderall and he had he had the
Adderall going this is the 100 dude this
guy Regina wants to know if there will
be a cocaine shark uh actually actually
is that true so there's a story there's
a story about cocaine shark and
Elizabeth Banks the director of cocaine
bear said she would be totally game to
make cocaine shark so I think it's a
good movie if if it does well in the box
office and enough people go see cocaine
bear then I don't see it outside the
Roman possibility that she ends up
directing and making
uh uh cocaine shark gaves in the Lilac
room
I mean can you refute that I I can't I
can't I can change the color on the
lights these are just [__] facts okay
look we're just blowing up don't care
about your feelings okay [__] your
feelings the facts don't care yes I know
guys I need to put stuff up over here
yeah yeah over here well we some busy
[__]
um let's see what else in the comments
do we have before we go to the uh
Adderall ridden and the Adderall bear
that seat pack the Adderall bear I don't
know giving giving giving Trump the name
bear feels like we're giving him too
much credit oh yeah like
um like maybe Adderall sloth or
something oh okay or something something
that wouldn't be like it's not totally
dangerous or threatening and also I
think like a bear is like oh yeah I'm a
[__] bear I'm masculine no also yeah
but see I'm gonna well I shouldn't ruin
this for you I shouldn't ruin this
um the gender of the bear no cocaine
bear no what is it female I I can't say
I won't I won't I won't I will not
pronoun anyone or the bear does it have
blue hair Tony it does it's a blue hair
get out of here with that whoa listen
listen I'm telling you there is nothing
that you can say about this movie that
you're gonna go oh well uh that really
ruined it for me I mean literally it is
a a bear who has had way too much
cocaine it's just it's cocaine bear
that's what it is I mean like Sharknado
you know that it's gonna be a tornado of
sharks like right yeah whatever what
else are you [__] expect I feel like
though I mean like obviously you've seen
it but I would say probably the
difference in Sharknado and cocaine bear
is that there's better actors acting and
there's just better scenes that are
happening I don't know
Adderall aardvark
that's a yeah alliteration the comments
well alliterations are the best yeah
yeah yeah they're the they're the
easiest way to go yeah like they're the
you know path of least resistance
they're like water in the nickname world
right right yeah right I mean I'm just
saying it's it's true oh you doubt me
did anyone in the movie uh because
somebody somebody uh zkr99 says Snakes
on a Plane uh LSD lizards oh LSD I don't
know if I would give them that though
that's that's a premium drug I don't
think they know how to deal with that
premium as if listen as if cocaine isn't
are you serious I mean look cocaine I
mean it's readily available but that
doesn't mean it's not top shelf I mean
trust me I come from Missouri I come
from Missouri where they cook [__]
meth in a bathtub with Drano and [__]
Sudafed okay if I were to rank it I
would put cocaine underneath LSD in the
same way that I put shrooms above all
this like I'm I'm more of a
hallucinogenic type of uh
fan uh Coke is man whatever you like you
like the um you like the alternate
reality type thing well I just like the
ones that are able to let me explore my
creative thinking my space you know uh
not the one that's gonna try to get me I
don't know it's a I go
I I don't have a great pass with that
the the cocaine you know
I'm not a big fan of it it's just
because she seems like it seems like all
your Don Juniors gets you actually are
look what I'll say is this you get with
your dealer and you're like look I gotta
do another skit it's really it's for
work it's for work man it's for work the
way the way the way that I uh look at
cocaine it's very much like it's a party
drug and somebody's like it's like oh my
dealer's coming around they're gonna go
you know they go get it
when it's just like it like doesn't do
anything in the sense of like what you
would want it to do right that's just
that and again that's just that's just
my opinion allegedly from what I've
heard
you've no experience one experience when
you're on YouTube says cocaine trumpy
bear that that my friend would make a
good commercial yeah we need to have
cocaine trumpy bear commercial Gabe it
is a thing we have to do now I'm writing
it down right now you know what you
should do we should get um we should get
John Walsh see if he wants to do so
because he boy he does Trump let's see
when you get John Walsh to help us with
a a trumpet I'm writing it down I'm
writing it down okay good good
um 99.99 trumpy bear for a limited time
only oh boy speaking of cocaine trumpy
bear uh let's see you know what I should
probably just start with the [__] the
most
uh Hitler like
um clip here let me see if I can find
that [__] back he
he wants to go after uh enemies right
did you catch that part then he's I've
seen a lot of stuff I I haven't gone
through all of it yet because like I
said I literally have I downloaded and I
had to transcribe through my editing
software so I could easily search for
these clips because people have like
C-SPAN clips and they've got rsbn clips
and they've got news max clips and
they've got uh real voice a real
America's voice on there all these clubs
I'm trying to have a consistent thing so
I'm looking at all the clips but now I
have three days worth of footage which
is like I don't know some close to 30
hours of footage and I have to go
through and but now now I can just
search for the keywords so when you've
got John Kennedy talking about how he
literally said this he goes by the way I
don't like kale I'd rather be fat
was his line and that was like that's
I mean other than Mr Potato Head that
you complained about that was like he's
like I'm going out but he also said Dr
Zeus I don't know who Dr Zeus I don't
know who Dr Zeus is either I mean but
again I've heard of a Dr Seuss but not
an accent the accent that he has I you
know I'm sympatheticorn [__] because it
is so real it is salsa so I can see how
it's real I can see how it's Dr Zeus I
could see a doctor Salsa Salsa
I knew someone would make fun of me I
knew they'd get there oh oh you're gonna
make fun of John Kennedy for the Z's on
the essence [__]
but actually from if I remember
correctly it's not Dr Seuss if I
remember correctly the way that it's
pronounced is uh soyce
we've been saying it wrong this whole
time yeah yeah I'm pretty sure because I
did a video on like in 2020.
oh God damn when they were like oh Dr
Seuss is yeah
it's pronounced
s-o-i-c-e like voice it rhymes with
voice
so everyone thinks it's Dr Seuss like
Zeus
or moose but it actually is Choice we've
been like this whole time we've been
lied to this entire [__] time just
like we should have a no I I'm gonna
I'll put a graphic in for uh
for moments like this we're just gonna
have the more you know thing come by
it's like the more you know no you
thought you knew you thought you you
thought you knew you thought you knew
but you normally didn't but yeah doctor
the way that you actually supposed to
say it is Dr soyce listen
so this is why I say Matt Getz is
because it's not [__] spelled Gates
okay [__] that guy that's not how I
think the AE Gates yes no I don't give a
[__] I'm giving [__] about English have
you noticed that I don't give a sh I
don't give a [__] about pronouncing
stuff I shouldn't be so good
oh I woke up to the wrong sounding name
you know what it probably is is that not
enough people like towel Dr soyce would
say it because soyuz doesn't sound as
cool as Seuss yeah can I get some soy
sauce right soys no it doesn't sound as
good so [__] you it's Dr Seuss I'm just
saying it's the way it is saying
Dr soy sauce You're Not Gonna Cancel
Seuss's name [__]
oh okay here's the quote that I think is
the um
the best quote that he had is in his
entire speech he's really trying to out
Hitler Donald all right excuse me and
well Donald Trump but uh Rhonda Santos
here oh my God who couldn't even show up
right yeah [__] what a [__] when you've
got two people who are I mean I'm
surprised Nikki Haley showed up honestly
gotta give her props for that but the
fact that you who run who shot him Nikki
Haley who is this I don't know dude you
know Nikki Haley dude Nikki Haley yeah
okay she was like I'm not racist I took
down that Confederate flag right and
everyone else is like no be racist and
she's like I know I really am racist
she's like oh it was a mistake that I
did this yeah she's like oopsies whoops
uh but I'm surprised that she showed up
obviously because you're gonna know that
any main Republican event you're going
to have Donald Trump headlining right
you're gonna have this Mega filled
convention or raller sparsely filled as
we saw with photos oh no oh no he he is
true thing this morning so it has to be
[__] that this is it was a huge
crowd no matter what nobody says the
biggest crowd ever in the history of
ever ever they're standing room only
even the fire department had trouble
letting them in or some [__] I'm not
kidding you he said that [__]
um this is the quote for those who have
been wronged and betrayed I am your
retribution now
I want to tell you what I I believe
about this clip in so many different
ways
um but let's just listen to it first in
the White House their reign is over
their rain will be over
and they know it and America will be a
free Nation once again we're not a free
Nation right now so okay let's uh we're
just gonna take a tick by dick here so
what he's saying is is look you put me
back in and they'll never take power
again that's what he's saying here
that's pretty uh pretty much like a
dictator I think I think
um the word arrives with smartarian no
yeah if we're talking about words that
don't exist Miss moritarian I think it
rhyme whatever this is it rhymes with
that
so I'm just saying but hey I mean you're
just saying I mean what am I supposed to
I I didn't make this [__] say
this stupid [__] I did not make him say
this and really no one did but here's
the point that I want to make is that
this is why Mike Pompeo because I'm
going to show you that what a bonehead
this guy Mike Pompeo it's so funny he's
worse than Nikki Haley but
um hey I just I just think it's
hilarious that people still are talking
about how Rhonda santis could win this
like what are you talking where listen
it is [__] Mar it was March 4th we
are we are 18 months or at least a year
before any primary start and this dude
is talking about taking over the country
and turning it into a fascist State and
getting retribution on his political
enemies
and you think you think you think that
Rhonda Santos is gonna have a shot and
[__] in hell yeah at this point
everyone's like oh well he'll get in in
June by June Ronda santis will look so
small in this race it won't even be
funny yeah and I'm here for it I'm here
for Trump destroying Santos I mean we
should we should 100 divide the two make
them pick is it run or is it Trump which
one is it going to be is it going to be
Don or Ron Don V Ron who's it gonna be
ding ding who are you going to pick and
that's why you have to make them choose
you have to make them
take a stance put their [__] foot in
the ground and say I am backing Ron
DeSantis or I am backing Donald Trump
whichever but they can't it was clear
that CPAC um it was clear that seat back
backs Donald Trump they made him the
headliner not Ron DeSantis and that's
why Rhonda that's the reason why Ron
didn't show up is because he wasn't the
headliner yeah because it only if Rhonda
if Rhonda Santos would have showed up on
day one or day two ahead of Donald Trump
it would have owned what are you on a
mango background now is that mango delay
was lilac but now it's mango
um
I'll fix it in a sec no that's good I I
like it that way oh you like it this way
sure okay No Light No Light all right
whatever so so
um if Ron if Ron if meatball Ron would
have showed up
um in front of Donald Trump
he it would have showed that you are not
the headliner you were not the leader
you weren't you're not going to win and
it would have only it would have only
put a bigger Spotlight on that and
Donald Trump would have taken advantage
of that so Rhonda Santos not going was
actually politically the right choice
for Rhonda Santas yeah it really was it
was I mean like if you can imagine if
you if you you know based on what you've
seen on Truth social that Donald Trump
is is not really holding anything back
right he's attacking Nikki Haley
attacking Iran DeSantis these are all
people who were uh in his Corner every
step of the way right they were they
they took every stride with him
and the fact that Ron DeSantis in there
is a big tell because it shows you that
either that you know match lap uh isn't
for him or you know they're trying to
send a message that CPAC doesn't back
Ron DeSantis they back Donald Trump and
this you know until the next uh CPAC
that happens they're going to continue
to push that idea right unless something
crazy happens I mean he even said and
we'll play in a clip obviously the whole
indictment
uh topic comes up but they
are using this as a way to further the
idea that Trump despite the fact that
there really wasn't much people many
people there watching inside this in
CPAC it does show you that they are
trying to push this narrative that
Donald Trump is the nominee right he's
going to be the nominee they're going
there is I I'm trying to remember
who gave this speech in 2020 I think it
was at Kimberly girlfoyle in 2021 at
CPAC she said Trump is not going
anywhere he is here to stay and I only
know that because I've been reviewing
footage from past cpacs to put in this
upcoming what was that
but she literally said in 2021 Trump is
not going anywhere he's here to stay
and this just goes to show you two years
later they are stuck with him whether
they like it or not because he is the
only person that can drive enough people
through xenophobia hate racism bigotry
whatever it might be to go vote in the
polls right he'll lose he'll [__]
lose big time right yeah he ain't gonna
lose the primary exactly he ain't gonna
lose the prime he will lose the general
but and listen I believe this line right
here this next uh it's about a minute
long this next little minute that he has
he because I believe he was going to
lose by about 14 million I believe he's
up to about 15 million now that he's
going to lose in 2024 with this with
this next minute listen
we don't have Free Press we don't have
free anything
in 2016 I declared I am your voice today
I add I am your Warrior I am your
Justice and I am your J okay hail Caesar
what the [__] are you serious I am your
justice but this next one this next one
proves to me that this guy is super
pissed that we [__] told him to [__]
off by 8 million votes this is the line
that proves that he knows that eight
million more people 81 million people
did not vote for Joe Biden a shitload of
those people voted against Donald Trump
because they [__] hate his guts and
they think he's a loser listen And for
those who have been wronged and betrayed
I am your retribution I am your
retribution because he means I've been
wrong I've been betrayed and I'm gonna
get retribution that's what he's saying
he always says the quiet part out loud
he's always projecting and and again
because here here's why it's all
[__] and it's his retribution
because the people he's talking to like
the insurrectionist and all the election
deniers out there and all the people who
are gonna go to prison for this
[__] thousands of people are
gonna go to prison for this [__]
thousands they're literally history
books are going to tell that how many
thousands of people went to [__]
prison
for this goddamn guy's delusion that he
won now
he could have fixed that before he left
office Gabe Sanchez he just said I
pardon all of you he could have pardoned
the whole Jam sick prison choir right he
could have before they ever sang that
God you're gonna creepy ass tune
he could have pardoned them I am
absolutely pardon them and said ah go
free my children into the wild to go
commit crimes again but he didn't but he
didn't he well now he he pardoned some
of them you know like playing people
that helps him make more money right or
well continues this idea right yeah
right well let's let's finish up this uh
clip here this retribution clip he's
gonna get retribution on us
yourself
they're excited in the room for fascism
by the way
[Music]
I will totally obliterate the Deep State
I will fire
[Applause]
are you are you the Deep State because I
mean I mean there's a lot of times when
I hear people at CPAC give these
speeches and I'm like are you just
talking in a mirror like are you are you
saying this to yourself about yourself
it is projection if that's what you're
wondering yeah I mean it's it's just one
of those things where you're like look
you guys didn't
actually help right you deepen the swamp
and you made it more [__] swampy well
that's just meant by drain the swamp is
yeah yeah but drain you know drain drain
one other swamp into a to make a bigger
swamp right you know and throw in more
swamp creatures right that's what we
want let's listen
by the way I want to point out his
makeup it's getting worse right I mean
you know people need to remember too
like I don't know how bright the lights
are or where they're positioned but like
when you're on stage you got to have a
lot of lights going on you know right
and I think this is one of those things
where
you know sometimes you have nothing to
look orange he doesn't even want orange
anymore it's almost like a I don't know
what that color is but it looks like
[__] it's kind of it's like uh you know
what it looks like it looks more like
not an orange but a gold like you know
how like like uh performers outside will
be like Oh I'm a gold statue kind of
thing yeah okay it's like an off-brand
gold color like they couldn't quite get
full gold so they got like halfway gold
or maybe they mixed his orange paint in
with the gold it's definitely possible I
mean like that's what like it looks
it looks like he's got a golden kind of
glow to his face
at least from this angle I don't know
someone's pointing out on Facebook that
he's got a turkey neck I don't believe
that really is uh someone else say
turkey that's an insult to turkey necks
this is more like a uh ballchinian it's
kind of are you know some other sort of
genitalia okay let's let's continue
foreign
[Music]
the funniest part is his Expressions
here at the end is that he thinks he's
really cool and tough yeah I mean he
says I am your Warrior a warrior are you
[__] kidding me the guy I think it's
five times he had a doctor try to excuse
him from being recruit uh drafted into
the war because of bone spurs or
education
which are all hilarious reasons uh some
you know for for for most people who did
it are legitimate but for Donald Trump
he's a [__] ass [__] right we know
this he is we know this to be true we
know he gets triggered we know he gets
upset we know that he literally used the
federal government to try to take to
have Twitter take down a tweet by uh uh
by
um wow why am I looking at her name
right now
John Legend's wife yeah
um Chrissy Teigen Jesus [__] me up I'm
sorry I'm sorry but the fact that you
know you have Donald Trump who avoided
getting drafted into the war but from
bone spurs and other excuses got upset
that there was a tweet out there you
know he gets upset for other things as
well when everyone insults him or makes
fun of him or he's the butt of the joke
which is a lot of times this guy gets so
mad that he tries to say you know what
I'm gonna I'm gonna take my [__] I'm
gonna come back at you I'm gonna get my
revenge I am so petty but it's not like
the same type of petty where you'd be
like oh that person's Petty that I got
back at them for this like little [__]
and like oh man they owned him so well
Donald Trump is the guy who has a
[__] tantrum
and it goes beyond the idea of petty
right it's like so childish and so like
oh come on man you're an adult you're
like a [__] senior citizen right now
and this this is what you're gonna live
out the rest of your days doing it's
pathetic
and on brand for the guy but well of
course it is I'm gonna show you that
this next clip here is
him whining about journalists telling
the truth just what you're talking about
oh you're telling the truth I hate that
and he knew it was a fake story
and when it was finally revealed now the
times the worship will say well admit it
was a fake story we're trying to get the
Pulitzer Prize taken away they got
Pulitzer Prize we keep saying that [__]
they're not gonna do it what does that
even mean he's like look the Russia gate
has been proven false no it hasn't we're
trying to get closer to do this he's
he's tried multiple times
right is because the bullets are they
gave the prime this is very accurate
reporting it's it's groundbreaking
reporting Washington Post New York Times
and the third one I'm blanking on but I
definitely know it was those two they
got Pulitzer Prize for the reporting on
the whole russiagate collusion
interference and he wants to be like oh
no it's not true we've proven it's not
true no you haven't you have not proven
it was not true the fact that you're
complaining about it still to this day
and you tried to say oh you know we
requested via our lawyers that uh they
they get it pulled from Pulitzer and
Pulitzer needs to you know issue an
apology Poulter came out like
nope we're not gonna do that uh we have
done our fact checking and we support
the award that we gave because it was
good reporting yeah right because they
reported it they checked it they gave
them the [__] price now what's
hilarious about this is he's like we
should we should take that away from him
and the reason why he wants to take it
away from him here's here's the truth
because it is the truth what they
reported is the [__] truth no
collusion no corruption or whatever the
or no collusion no obstructions yeah
it's all [__] it's all lies and
that's why he wants to take it away but
you know as scummy as Pulitzer is for
giving them the prize he wants them to
give other people the lives right what's
their new phone who this
Steve on YouTube let's let's listen to
who he wants to give it to this is a
[__] crazy ass [__] we're suing we're
suing we're suing you could sue anyway
what the prize is for its concise and
accurate reporting he always they always
run into it yeah like he's mad that it's
right and let's continue he's gonna give
it to though remember what remember what
the prize says he just said it now let's
see who he's gonna put it's he goes to a
list of examples of who he wants to get
this price on the Russia Russia Russia
event
and they have it actually totally wrong
actually Mark Levin should get a prize
and Greg Jarrett
Jared should get her prize
and even it's not his deal
Sean Hannity
should get a prize what the [__] I mean
he's just what's funny is so there's
this there's this riff between Rupert
Murdoch and Donald Trump yeah right
Rupert Murdoch is basically told most of
his Network [__] this guy we are not
gonna we are not gonna support his
campaign [__] him he's on his own right
and he's pissed off about that Steve
bannon's pissed off about it maga's
pissed off about it so what he's doing
here is he is sucking at the teat of the
Fox News host because and he continues
this I'm gonna show you he continues
this because he wants those hosts to
Buck
Rupert Murdoch and the Murdoch Sons I
get them it's not gonna happen what are
you talking about they're literally
being sued for pushing the big lie that
this guy complained about right they
knew that it was bad and they tried to
play it up and now they're being sued
for 1.6 billion dollars by Dominion
voting systems and the idea that they
[__] line they knew they lied it's
not because it's not because they were
like oh we reported misinformation
inadvertently they were like texting
each other like this is all [__] but
we're gonna put it on the air anyway but
I think what we're gonna well I think
there's gonna be something interesting
that happens right you've got Donald
Trump and Rupert Murdoch who are going
at each other right and I think I saw a
tweet that was reporting I haven't done
the to fact check it but it was saying
that Fox News I guess has internally
said do not
platform him ever like in the future
like we there's so much [__] that we're
going through right now with this
lawsuit we cannot platform him even
further so do not air anything from him
right because all he everything he says
is defamatory right exactly right I mean
it I mean they would have to they what
they would have to do and here's one
reason why Rupert Murdoch and and fox is
actually doing him a favor by doing that
is because they would literally have to
fact check him in real time on the air
on Fox News to his [__] supporters
over and over and over again so they're
really doing him a favor by not covering
him right right not covering him they're
doing it and so what I what I think
we're also going to see is if you've got
a group of people who are Maga right and
they love Trump and they see that Fox
News is anti-trump or at least is not
supporting Trump publicly right the
question there becomes will they go
there anymore to hear about Trump if
he's not being platformed anymore if
he's not being displayed or shown or
talked about or promoted then would they
go there anymore right the only other
people that could do it is potentially
Sean Hannity or Tucker Carlson but even
them you know that's one of those things
but I look at this and I say all right
if you've got a group of an umbrella of
Republicans and you've got your you know
center right Republicans and you got
your like conservative Republicans you
got your mega Republicans and you throw
the extremists in there too your mag
Republicans I feel like have begin to
lose that demographic and they move over
to Newsmax and oan and whatever who also
again are uh you know have their own
lawsuit going on but at the end of the
day like I wonder like who's willing to
right feature him more but here's the
thing who is going to survive these
Dominion lawsuits Newsmax and oan who
who have no [__] uh subscription
contracts or Rupert Murdoch who's one of
the richest [__] in the world
yeah who owns who owns countless media
Outlets yeah Wall Street journals
right that he profits off this sludge
and not not only that there there is no
other conservative media news Outlet
like Fox News that has the contracts
that Fox News has with satellite and
cable companies the reason why Fox News
is so effective is because of their
business model and they know it now they
were scared of losing viewership and but
they don't give a [__] really about
viewership they do but but their
business model is not based off
viewership folks it is based off they
get a percentage of every single if you
got DirecTV
if you got DirecTV if you got any kind
of cable company
and and you get Fox News on that cable
company and you pay them x amount of
dollars 100 bucks whatever it is Fox
News is getting a is getting a part of
that hundred bucks every time you
[__] pay it it's not all based on
Advertising that's why Fox News isn't
that scared when they lose advertisers
they're not scared to say this type of
[__] because they're not relying on
advertisers just like here we're not
relying on advertisers I don't rely on
advertisers so I can say whatever the
[__] I want I mean to a certain extent
yeah yeah YouTube kicked me off but you
know that's their that's their deal not
mine
oh okay so let's let's go back to this
uh clip listen to who else on Fox News
this is [__] hilarious this this is
great listen
and frankly Jesse should get us get a
surprise
I'd say Jesse should get the prize now
he's talking about Jesse Waters he's
saying Jesse Waters should get eight
prize like a participation trophy maybe
maybe that's what he's talking about I
don't know which is funny when you were
which is funny because you you look at
uh
you you look at the Republicans like oh
man all you little you woke kids and
your participation Awards and this and
that so you're saying everyone should
just get an award because they reported
on something that was completely false
like you like he knows he knows he's
wrong but he doesn't want to admit it
because that means that every if one
thing is wrong then all things are wrong
especially when he's campaigned since
2020 on this idea that the election was
stolen right and you know Mike Lindell
is also being sued for 1.3 billion
dollars and that guy continues to do
[__] I don't know if you a quick side
note I don't know if you saw but there's
a photo going on that is real from a
reporter a journalist who is at CPAC and
he was like I'm surprised they even let
me still come here but there's a there's
a message on the screen for Mike Lindell
that says you've gone up you you've gone
over like seriously hurry up you've gone
over like wrap it up uh which I thought
was hilarious uh and I haven't really I
thought it was fake no that's real that
is that is real everyone was like is
that real and he's like I'm literally
sitting in the pit right now where the
timer is yeah yeah because I because I
was um I was saying earlier that that
the way that it was set up in that room
um looks really awkward for like when
you get the back shot but but it but you
have to understand they had the camera
stage Center
um because they have so many [__]
Trader news networks that wanted to
broadcast this stupid yeah so they had
they have the pit so typically when
you're given a presentation you've got a
pit below which is where photographers
can get right close shots yeah and then
they also have
um sometimes it it didn't have the front
row seats
even the camera stages behind which even
those seats weren't even filled to to uh
to capacity right which I thought was
hilarious I was like I would think that
if you were to show that especially like
during Don Juniors like look under your
seat is there a golden chocolate bar Ah
that's a great and that's a great one
and over there's no one sitting in these
seats so no one got golden bars yeah I
think that's like two people look at
gold bars because one of them was behind
so they had like a barricade gate up and
there's one guy behind the barricade
gate who's like I got a chocolate bar I
got one and I was like so two people is
that the Willy Wonka moment that you're
talking about yeah yeah it'll make it
it'll make a uh I'll have a Willy Wonka
little clip on on what was that what was
that yeah okay good good I got the
golden ticket I got the golden ticket
okay he continues with this
who he wants to win a prize a
participation Pulitzer let's listen
just you should Jesse and a lot of
people and I'll tell you you know who
she got a prize Tucker should get a
prize
he almost forgot Tucker I know oh that
is hilarious he almost forgot Tucker
Carlson can you pull it can you go back
to the screen real quick yeah what what
so I I'm a big fan of the of the chirons
that they have right yeah so and I've
said this before in in previous like
speeches he's had but they always
promote certain things right they're
like they're selling [__] they're
selling [__] at the same time so right
now it's get a simple hard test check
your heart out in two minutes and
they'll have a link right uh the so
that's with Newsmax they always have
those and then with the rsbn one they'll
have on the side it'll be like Trump uh
Trump's children book of History uh yeah
stuff comes in uh it'll be some sort of
other retirement thing where basically
people are stealing your money and
scamming you and then there's another
one which is around there's like similar
memorabilia thing that they're all
selling with his image on it do they
sell the trumpy Bears on there no they
don't sell choppy Bears on there it's
like it's basically like three items
like we should do the trumpy cocaine
bear and buy buy time when he's speaking
unlike [__] do you think that they would
take it or you think I mean I don't know
I don't know it's surely we could sneak
it in it's like look guys I know that
you're [__] wouldn't that be [__]
hilarious like you want money you know
it would be [__] great oh my God
should we get a [__] like a GoFundMe
going to try to get the trumpy cocaine
trumpy bear and I'm gonna go look for I
don't know if I'll probably get free
beer we would probably get sued by
trumpy bear because that's a real thing
they it's not satire I guess I always
thought it was Santa you know what I I
haven't I haven't
I have a name but I won't say it on the
show okay all right I don't want to ruin
again okay all right well but what I am
saying is yes uh I could make a
commercial and I will because
we're gonna write that [__] this week
yeah we're gonna uh I need to go I have
to do a little bit of research though
we're gonna have to go back and watch
these uh those Google actually no I can
make that [__] no I can here's the thing
when you're making parody right you're
making like a parody commercial of
something you can feature the company I
mean as long as it's not I know I guess
what I'm saying because of what I'm
saying with cocaine so it might be like
what I'm doing your image whatever what
I'm saying though is the problem is is
that those commercials feel like satire
in parody have you seen that oh no I've
seen it yeah he rides on the back go
find one of those [__] go find
one of those right now I want to show
that I know it's off topic but it's
really not I mean
I mean he is it feels it feels fake but
it is real right it's true also these
things are not uh
uh not cheap no well let me let me while
you're finding let me show you a clip
here of him um
Stormy Daniels was rent free inside this
guy's head ever since she's like yeah
he's got a small dick like he can't let
it go he can't let it go listen to this
to bring charges against me for now
ancient know a fast story of Stormy
horse face Daniels no attract what kind
of story he couldn't even get that one
out he was like what he's what do you
say listen listen to what he says
to bring charges against me for
now ancient know Affair story of Asian
new Fast store what is ancient know a
fast story I don't know what that is are
you clear is that illegal is that a
legal term I don't even know I mean
that's like Kofi he's like I'm a morning
cup of coffee and what the [__] Morning
Star history yeah what's up what's the
horse face what okay he calls her horse
face though yeah and I think he does it
several times let's listen stormy horse
face Daniels no attraction
no Affair I call it no affair
where there is no crime anyway okay so
what he's saying there is he was
attracted to her he did try to have sex
with her I think he did actually I think
that's what she said right that's what
yeah she said it was the worst literally
the worst 90 seconds of my life right so
clearly he had an attraction at least 90
seconds of it clearly there was an
affair he was with Melania at the time
and I think she was she was pregnant
with Barron Trump at the time and he did
90 seconds of pump and dump and then and
then he says no crime which he's telling
you out loud when he says he's like look
I I am yeah I had sex with her and yeah
you know like you know I had a check
that was made out or a couple checks
that were made out to the to the the
total number of 130 000 and I had
Michael Cohen hey hey Dad you can you
can actually I I don't actually think
it's against the law to pay someone 160
130 whatever whatever the amount is no
not at all
um what is illegal
is why they were paying it and then who
actually paid it to cover it up and then
who he paid to cover it up because as
Michael Cohen has set out in the public
he said it right out in the open is that
Michael Cohen wrote the [__] check
and then and then Donald Trump was
writing the agreement was to write
checks back to Mike uh Michael Cohen's
wife to hide the [__] payment yeah
and that's why Michael Cohen decided to
take a guilty plea so his wife wouldn't
be roped into the case
so and because there's different things
that go on with spouse and how you can
testify against him and all that [__]
but what he's clearly saying in this
clip let me let me play it again if you
didn't hear it he's clearly saying it
Daniel's no attraction yes there's
attraction yeah no Affair yes there was
no fair he calls it no Affair but there
is one where there is no crime anyway
so there was crime for sure because
there are two here are the two scenarios
that Donald Trump has to admit if he did
in fact pay which we know that he did
this this this affair happened right
and this is why Alvin Bragg is coming
after him for uh business and election
um
uh uh fraud because what happened was
he paid Stormy Daniels via Michael Cohen
uh to do this right and it was right
before the 2016 election
now Donald Trump says never happened
never happened or he says on true social
oh it's way past the statue of
limitations it's not no uh and he goes
it's very well known it's old
horse-faced Stormy Daniels which is like
okay this is one of those scenarios
first off where a little kid goes to a
little girl and says oh do you want to
be my girlfriend and she goes no or do
you like me yes no you know kind of
thing and then the boy's like well I
didn't even like you anyway you're ugly
right that's that is what I get from it
is like the playground kid whoa are you
telling me wait are you telling me he's
a petulant child because this is new I
am telling you that breaking news
breaking news you heard it here first
Gabe Sanchez says that Donald Trump is a
petulant child who has the emotional
maturity of a kid on a playground asking
another girl or or boy if they like them
do you know what a person says no you
know what I want in times like that you
know Dash dabrowski is yeah yeah big
news I need I need to cut one of his
videos yeah and just put it in here when
when something like that big news big
news big news I like cash I like Dash by
the way but the other so what I was
saying was the two things that Alvin
Bragg is is going or the the one thing
that he's going after is to prove that
the amount of money that he paid was
actually a violation of Elections you
know it was it was fraud
um or violated election uh rules
uh because there's two scenarios here
either Donald Trump says yes I did pay
Stormy Daniels for this uh and then it's
like okay well uh Ben then that's a
crime you've literally committed a crime
and you admitted to a crime or Donald
Trump has to say no I never paid her
right uh but he or rather he did pay her
but he has to say either it was for the
affair
or it was for the election right and
then people say well allegedly if you
didn't have this affair why were you
paying for it so he's stuck in a corner
he has to either admit that he paid to
cover up so there was no damaging
information for the election or he had
to pay to cover up so Milan but he's
saying he's saying out loud but that's
exactly what it is
um it's hard to be like oh that's what
the actual truth is because it's like oh
I was speaking out I was you know
speaking out a term or I was speaking
yeah
um here is the trumpy bear Fisher
commercial you pulled it up first let's
play it the wind whispered through the
forest a storm is coming you cannot
defeat the storm from the trees Rose a
resounding voice I fear nothing I come
when the trumpet sounds
what
what they do what when the trumpet
sounds comes
oh my God this is gonna be so easy do
you have any idea how easy this is gonna
be we don't even have to change a lot
really no no no
I I'm gonna I'm gonna back it up I want
to hear that again let me see what it
says
nothing I come when the trumpet sounds I
am the source the Great American Grizzly
introducing the original trumpy bear the
this is [__] real yeah
there's a comment when whenever we're
done watching this video look at the
first comment in this YouTube video okay
so everyone can see because it's
probably the truest statement and I feel
this every day
this is this is insanity because when I
first saw this I was like this is
hilarious they're making fun of trump
yeah no no no no no no and then and then
it and and then I saw it
um on like a some sort of it might have
been on Jimmy Kimmel he made fun of it
right well but I saw it on a TV show
that they were actually playing and then
I'm like oh it's got to be someone who's
tricking Trump supporters into buying
this stupid [__] nope no it's [__]
real it's real okay let's keep going
Fearless super plush American grizzly
trumpy bear was born June 14th Flag Day
just find the secret zipper and pull out
the flag blanket then wrap yourself in
the red white and blue for comfort and
warm so
look at this look at this trumpy bears
humping the [__] flagpole with a flag
game what the [__] what the [__] this is
it is it's so funny because we know that
Donald Trump loves to grope and molest
the American flag right some Republicans
are like dude it's for saluting not for
[__] molesting right uh but the fact
that there's an American flag that pulls
out of the back of this guy like a cape
like he's a [__] super bear
hero kind of thing because as we know
with the American flag anything that you
do to it that is not as an American flag
you're desecrating the flag but
Republicans love it they put on the
[__] shorts their hats their socks
their underwear their bikinis a cape uh
I wonder if pictures with the diapers I
wonder if it comes with a diaper maybe
honestly maybe that's the addition I
guess so maybe that's the new you can
add on you like buy a little trumpy bear
diaper and it also in the in the uh
trumpy bear Deluxe yeah okay let's
continue oh you're patriotism and
proudly display trumpy on Flag Day and
on any American holiday trumpy can even
honor your own family God bless America
and God bless trumpy bears
look at this look at this Alpha I said
on the motorcycle man you you look at
this scene even the one before that
where it's like oh you've got the flag
of a fallen soldier your family member
and you've got a medal for that that
that family member and then you decide
you decide the more the the most
appropriate way to help remember their
life and their service is to put a
[__] stuffed bear with comb over
orange hair in the middle of it between
two candles as if that's the [__] uh
uh just that's that is the the
representation of how you would remember
someone's life right that is the the
[__] Idol that you have there Brooke
says you gotta do a parody of this the
problem is
this is already now it's unintentional
but it's unintentional satire of these
of who they are it's it's unintentional
this this is why it is difficult to do
parody and satire these people because
they are the parody in zantar right they
are they are the embodiment of it it's
difficult one's a watch I'm a former
Marine and I'm proud to have trumpy bear
ride by my side once a marine always a
marine everyone knows trumpy bear loves
to go to the golf course I ride the
trumpy bear he makes my golf game great
again thank you chunky bear simply
styled his trademark here and place them
in his favorite chair even though you
even got a style of tear like it's
maintenance right you gotta do
maintenance on this [__] you
know what else I find funny is the fact
that these people who are like [__]
I'm I'm Alpha bro I'm [__] tough as
[__] you can't [__] I'm not doing that
[__] ass [__] [__] right [__]
immunize and they're like but you know
what I will do I'll bring my little doll
if you can
if you know that you can put your hand
in his back to get a flag out there's
something I might be able to find
another compartment in there right other
things that are not so good well they
they love I wonder what kind of
genitalia it is you know these people
are obsessed with it I don't know man I
don't know what it could happen hmm
because guys will love trumpy bear when
America's great business is great when
business is great I am great I love you
trumpy bear I am an army veteran I am
proud to own the trumpy bear and I will
always be proud to be an American order
the super plus trumpy bear for only two
payments of 19. oh my God
the two [__] payments in 1990 yeah
that's how you do plus shipping and
handling go back to the business guy for
a sec
this guy yeah yeah if I saw a dude with
a [__] bear in the back that was like
oh no this is not like my kid's bear and
even then it'd be like yeah is that the
best setting to have a bear in there I
have no idea but you look at this and
you're like if you had a bear if you if
I walked in and I saw Trump repair I
would probably laugh hysterically
because I was like dude you are an adult
would you notice you notice that there's
this is a trumpy bear this is a plush
toy yeah and not one we haven't seen you
know a little kid with the trumpy bear
yet nope no kid all adults all people
also let's just let's just point out
this desk right now he has a globe a
calculator a mouse that's tightly
between a calculator and then the
keyboard and then a phone right next to
it
I'm right-handed so obviously I'm sure
left-handed people use it on the left
side but even so that like they didn't
even lay down through the layout of this
this looks like it's a it's a small set
that you would do like a real scene in
where you're like hey I need a 30 second
reel to show off this dramatic oh this
totally is just the this oh yeah all
back here is just yeah it's just Flats
they're not they're not real yeah it's
just drywall painted and you know got
some stuff on but this is not a real
office Norris is a real guy or a real
business person no no legitimate person
how much do you think he got paid to do
this commercial how much would you get
paid to do something like this 50 bucks
to deliver that line is that really what
you'd get paid you think it depends this
is not I don't think I mean no way this
is [__] sag uh it's a commercial so
and it's also you know the Distribution
on it I have no idea you basically could
get anyone you want you could say this
is a non-union commercial gig so you
don't have to pay sag fees because it's
not going to go you know commercially
across the us but then you would say
okay I'm
I'm casting and I need a roll here and
you could offer whatever you want you
can say 50 bucks 100 bucks 500 bucks
whatever it might be but then the person
says okay great and they sign a waiver
and they say I I sign over all rights of
my likeness in the representation of
this commercial
and then the people who made the
commercial I'm sure I'm sure that trumpy
bear people probably hired someone uh if
that and the people who are acting in
this none of them are real people it's
not a [__] Marine no well yeah I feel
kind of bad here's the thing down here
you see this disclaimer because they
[__] up by putting a make America
great again hand on this in the footage
because it says down here make America
great again as trademark of Donald J
Trump for president Incorporated
no endorsement is implied or granted hat
is not included and nor offered for sale
so they [__] up by putting and make
America great again hat on it because
then they had to put the disclaimer on
the footage let's let's keep going let's
go back to let's see oh yeah let's go
right here where grandpa is yeah grandpa
is hugging the [__] the bear it looks
like I don't know it looks like because
again you know like look if you need
that in your life
whatever but don't expect me to
uh
uh don't expect me to take you seriously
if you are an adult who tries to argue
that Republicans are tough and masculine
and not snowflakes who play with little
dolls and you know I have to dye their
hair blue and all this [__] you're
literally combing the hair of an
inanimate object because it resembles
Trump right it's got a tie and a collar
in in [__] cuffs
Debbie says dress it up and drag look
Trump dresses up in drag every day yeah
every day yeah there was also a drag
queen at CPAC whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
are you saying that Michael Knowles took
a picture with this my my ladies lady
Maga in 2019 I bet you were to go back
to 2019. you would probably find a photo
of Lady Maga and Michael moles yeah
Michael Knowles together out drinking
on a balcony
and he tweeted it and he still has it up
right well let's let's let's get to that
I want to finish this trumpy bear Thing
Up To Be An American order the super
plus trumpy bear for only two payments
of 19.95 and receive a special
certificate about oh you get
authenticity don't miss out on only in a
piece of American History order now for
only two payments of 19.95 trumpy the
most Fearless bear anywhere order now
do you think that people need a
certificate of authenticity to be like
oh yeah this is a real trumpy bear like
somebody's not gonna be like hey is that
a One of a Kind real trumpy bear and
like it is oh prove it and you're like
well here's my certificate it says so on
it oh my God
oh my God trumpy bear you [__]
kidding me well read the first no go
back go back oh son of a [__]
okay all right read the first comment
show the first comment in there because
I think it's the truest statement
uh Mike two years ago says and it's got
1300 thumbs up 67 replies remember when
you could tell the difference between
comedic Santa and reality those were the
days
oh those I mean every day you're like oh
that's a funny thing and then the next
day you're like oh nope that's uh that's
reality that's oh buddy [__] me
that is how it goes in this universe
okay so let's now that we've uh
successfully mocked
uh Donald Trump did you notice this
Twitter is [__] up man they are not
broadcasting this do you know that like
you can go to the Twitter broadcast look
at this
so you can go to the Twitter broadcast
and it shows the broadcast sort of when
they are there it is there's zero
viewers though but you'd have to go to
it it's not showing that's why people
are going to scan over wait where that's
right oh God
man all right he's a twit okay so
um here's why structure the tweet this
way
a lot of people are always like like our
haters are always like uh-huh five
viewers I'm like you don't get to see
the analytics dumb [__] yeah also if you
go to It's Like You on on Twitter there
are less people watching than on YouTube
which by the way right now on YouTube we
have over 1200 people watching live so
hello everyone thank you for watching
thanks for watching even our haters out
there who only think three people watch
this show okay good luck
um but here's why I structure the tweet
this way Trump here's the title and then
I say surf the Twitter Trends right
because we that's what we're doing and
then I put my website and then I put the
YouTube and the reason why I put my
website is so you can find it in case
this link fails for whatever reason but
I put the YouTube link almost every day
I fail sometimes in that measure but
almost every day and that is to get you
to go to YouTube and watch it not on
Twitter because on Twitter like when you
comment on Twitter I can't see it they
never it never shows me it doesn't even
show me in my notifications that you
commented on that yeah
um during the broadcast like in the
broadcast because Periscope they still
use Periscope but Periscope doesn't
translate for whatever yeah I don't know
they [__] changed it or maybe yeah
Periscope has been broken for a while in
terms of yeah and this may be a problem
of that where it's not broadcasting
because this is the Periscope link you
can see twitter.com uh Slash I slash
broadcast so that's the Periscope link
or Twitter like because Twitter is
because Periscope used to be an outside
tool and then Twitter bought it and then
they made an internal tool anyways the
point is the reason why I put the little
TV and the uh the show number behind
that is to break up these links so it
doesn't do this and it's still doing it
so [__] Elon [__]
let's see what else do we want to look
at let me let me get this off so we're
not scrolling no that's a good one oh
here's a good ah we won't show that
and I I there's too many other [__] that
we gotta show okay speaking of we're
gonna go to Tennessee here speaking of
drag queens do you know who this is
you know this is oh is that uh lee
huh no Tennessee no right here right
here you know who this guy is no you
ever heard of Bob Hope
oh yeah yeah yeah this is Bob Hope with
really big tits yeah
huge tits by the way
Bob must have had a thing for kazumbas
I'm just saying so this is um this is um
Jackie Gleason 1975.
this is Jackie Gleason and Bob Hope in
Central Park oh
so oh yeah I'm yeah I look at yeah I'm
looking you know what you know what's
funny you know you know you know who
loves them some Bob Hope you know who
loves them some Bob Hope all the uh huh
I said Hollywood well right but I mean
all these the airport named after him
well but all these but all these [__]
all these [__] people who want to
cancel drag shows we need to go back to
the days
the good old days like 1975 when Bob
Hope had a pair of bazooka boobs on yeah
come on man dudes have been dressing and
dragging performing drag for a long time
gay dude straight dudes Rudy Giuliani
Jesus Christ Donald Trump stuffed his
face in drag queen Rudy's tits on some
kind of [__] stupid video that they
did oh it was a it was a roast yeah
whatever it was yeah who gives it arrest
them arrest them arrest they're
sexualizing and they're gonna destroy
our children's Minds our arrest them I
mean this is this why why don't you have
boob hope I like it someone hurts
someone on someone on YouTube says I
totally missed it I told I'm sorry I
should have that was the easy target I I
I did it so I did a show in San
Francisco I had a running show where I
would me and my friend would Host this
uh this improv show in San Francisco for
I don't know over like around two years
and every Thursday I would dress up as a
character who
uh had huge tits right I had huge boobs
I had a dress I had a drag yeah I had a
wig and glasses sometimes I put on on
lipstick if I was you know if I felt
like dealing with taking it off later
but my character oh totally in totally
and it was very much like coffee talk
kind of like character like this like
that was the Persona uh that I would do
on stage
as this host judge of this show that we
would have and I did it for two years
and it was [__] amazing it was so fun
it was so great uh and I wore yeah so I
mean like I wore drag for two years in
San Francisco and it was awesome
you hear that everybody
you've seen Chase was a drag queen well
I mean
I think calling me a drag queen is not
like that's giving me too much credit
you're not that good no like I know drag
queens and San Francisco who are [__]
amazing right I was just I was just
someone who did it just had a just had
boobs yeah you were blue it was in San
Francisco I was boob hope of Sam it was
either like uh I either have like uh
like wool socks or like uh beanies to to
fill out this bra because the bra that
it was like this leopard this leopard
pink bra that I got at a
uh it was like at a like a discount
store somewhere in the mission in San
Francisco and I was like man these are
really big I gotta [__] feel these
things so I would always have to stuff
in like socks you know inside of inside
of the bra under this blouse Sherry says
drag princess so maybe you're a princess
other people are pointing out other
people who dressed up as as women church
lady
um on SNL yeah special that's special I
mean this is not new how in the [__] now
also it's like what do you think men did
when they performed Shakespeare
right they played women they played
women that's the whole [__] point
here's the craziest part about this is
that people like Michael Knowles here
who called he did call for the
eradication of transgender penis
multiple times [__] I don't give a [__]
if he said ISM or transgender people
whatever the [__] he said he wants to
eradicate transgender people there I I
know that it's confusing for these
right-wing cucks out there
that they get drag queens and
transgender people confused right
they're like oh if a man dresses up in a
dress then they're transgendered no
that's not I mean Bob Hope was not
transgender okay Dana Carvey is not
transgender they're just performing
performing
but they're getting confused and they
get these things mishmashed in their
little simple heads
and that's when you get this [__] in
Tennessee where it becomes dangerous
where they're trying to eradicate people
people I don't give a [__] what Michael
Noel says I said ISM yeah you said it on
purpose yeah you said it on purpose now
rolling stone actually changed this
headline uh to say trans transgenderism
um to eradicate it but they also wrote a
new headline
for a new story and here's the um
if I can find it well [__] is it Michael
Knowles is a hypocritical [__] ass
[__] well very close
um it's a CPAC speaker calls for the
eradication of transgenderism
and somehow claims he's not calling for
the elimination of transgender people is
this article still up is this the one
that they pulled yes this is May or
March 5th 2000 this is Peter Wade I took
this a screenshot which was the wasn't
there one that they had and they noticed
what it what it says here evil yeah
I mean it's true Rolling Stone got it
got it well you know a lot of people
were knocking Rolling Stone and um they
were kind of missing the ball but they
finally caught on that hey people aren't
gonna [__] people aren't gonna [__] with
his whole semantics of ism and
transgender people right we know what
you're saying [__] we know what you're
saying we know what the [__] you're
saying this is not an ideology these are
[__] people these are [__] human
beings these are Americans you [__]
slimy piece of [__] and I wish I had
time to play the damn clip again but I
don't
um we just don't have the time uh but I
did play it on patreon last night and I
went through it and I gave the contrast
of Joe Biden speaking in Selma to
commemorate Bloody Sunday at the Edmund
Pettis Bridge
um so you can go watch that on patreon
uh let's see but here's here's what I
want to get to here because not only in
Tennessee are they trying to ban
um drag queens and drag shows but
they're also trying to legislate
transgender people and others out of
existence
um and one way they're doing it is
they're passing a teacher bully bill
in [__] I'm serious it's crazy
they're trying to pass a bill that
allows teachers to call students
whatever they want
um now here is representative Justin
Jones in Nashville he's a Democrat
um listen to how he uh argues the points
of this bill but watch as he says what
he says and then they try to call points
of order on him I'll try to explain what
this means inside this meeting
um to give you an idea if people don't
understand some of that process of
debate inside of a conference like this
but listen I'm sorry
to you all I'm sorry about how the men
behind me are acting because what we're
seeing is bullying from those elected to
serve these people in the audience what
we're seeing is people using their power
to hurt the most vulnerable students in
our community and so uh Reverend Jones
we have a point of order chairman okay
so so what is happening is he's
addressing the audience in um in this
debate which in Tennessee the point of
order is that you have to address the
bill specifically you can't talk to the
audience right as if they're Witnesses
they're just there to see the process
they're not actually you're not to
address them you're to address the bill
so that's what the point of order is but
wait for when he asks if a teacher and
you can see the words up there if a
teacher wanted to refer to me by the
n-word would it be okay let's watch it
right can you recognize every time I
talk we call point of order we turn off
the microphone but I'm gonna have
questions to ask you do not
point of order is this is not on the
bill speaking to the audience is not on
the bill stay on the bill please all
right they want him to stay on the bill
because they don't want the truth they
don't want to be challenged they don't
want their ideas to be challenged they
don't want their hate to be challenged
because if it's challenged then people
will see for it what it truly is watch
all right thank you Mr chair you stated
that the sixth circuit case Merriweather
V heartthrob gave K-12 teachers the
right to misgender students when that
case explicitly States from the court if
you read it in full let me finish my
question if you don't mind that it shall
not be applied to K-12 teachers only
applies to University professors that is
the case you cited but you misled this
committees and gave us the wrong context
and definition is that correct that is
incorrect Meriwether does apply is it
about a an employee at a public
institution not being forced to speak
the members of this body also certainly
stand for the First Amendment and the
protections of the first amendments down
the bill and not talk about how this
body is Banning books if we want to talk
about the first amendment I won't get
into that
um so here's what they're doing in under
the designs of the first amendment in
Tennessee they're making it to where
teachers can call students whatever they
want yeah they can call them whatever
they want they could literally anything
that they want to refer to them as with
with no consequences and and they're
putting it in because folks what I'm
telling you you can keep [__]
doubting me on this but this is the road
that they're going down to take away
your consent of your children because
now they have moved from pronouns and
transgender children to all children and
protecting the racist bigoted [__]
teachers calling students whatever they
want without consequence and that is not
the first amendment that it's not the
first amendment you do not get to live
in a world where you get to say whatever
you want without consequence that's not
what it is stop hiding behind that but
listen listen to when he delivers this
line but what I will get into is a
question about Free Speech where is this
a problem where have have teachers been
fired in your school District or using
the incorrect pronoun where has this
been an issue in your District so again
there have been issues through I think
throughout the country Meriwether being
one of those cases there's cases in in
Virginia Kansas there is confusion so
he's got three cases three cases that
they're basing this entire bill on in
the entire country not in Tennessee and
the entire country to make sure that
teachers have the right to be hateful
towards students well that's the same
it's the same thing that you see them do
when they're like oh well you know what
these these trans athletes shouldn't
compete because they're going to do so
much better it's like okay let's look at
the numbers what are the actual numbers
of trans athletes that are performing
and also a lot of the people that are
being triggered are the parents the
parents who live vicariously and
desperately through their children to be
like look this kid we raised him or her
to have uh this much training and this
much experience on the stuff for these
Sports and I'm not going to let that
money go to waste because some man or
woman decides that they want to be a man
or woman whatever might be right
and they get so upset they get so upset
that somebody's trans and they said hey
look I feel comfortable not as a man but
as a woman and I want to be a swimmer
right and those people get so [__]
upset and they complain and use that one
one case to then justify all of the
bigotry and all of the laws and all of
the regulations that they want to put in
place to say that no trans athletes
can't compete in whatever
that that field is right whatever that
that sport uh is male female whatever
and they want to reject it someone
someone brings up and asks a question
here uh what kind of teacher wants this
law has nothing to do with teachers
there's no teacher out there Desiring to
[__] bully a student I mean there
there are some there are exceptions yeah
yeah the point is the point is is what
the Republicans in Tennessee want is the
ability to protect racist and bigots
because that's what they are right they
want to protect the con them they want
to protect themselves from consequences
of using their freedom of speech listen
and you're going to hear this line if a
teacher wanted to refer to me the the
the Congress the representative Justin
Jones I believe his name is now who is a
black man referred to me as the n-word
would that be okay
yes that's what they want they want the
ability for a teacher to refer to a stu
a black student as the n-word and it be
okay now that does not this law and no
law on the books now prevents a teacher
from calling a student then there's no
[__] law in Tennessee I'm sure that
prevents a teacher from calling a
student that there's [__]
consequences yeah yeah there's diary
and they don't and the reason why you do
that's you don't have to police this
[__] in this day and age is because
there's dire consequences to do it we
just watch teacher after teacher after
teacher get fired when they do that [__]
in a classroom because these students
have cell phones now but watch watch as
they respond to what he says Fusion in
Tennessee if the teachers say wanted to
refer to me by the n-word would that be
okay under your free speech definition
would you be okay on the bill on the
bill this is about the bill Mr chair no
it is not you can address that then
we're moving on of course see they
silence him yeah they silence that one
they do not do not want that question
they do well they don't want that
question answered because the answer is
yes the answer is yes they want to
protect a teacher a white teacher white
racist bigoted teacher they want him or
her to be able to call a black student
the n-word and protect him with the law
to protect their job to make sure that
teacher is held on high put on the news
oh they tried to fire this but look at
the law we passed to make sure she could
discriminate against a black student
yeah that's not what it is and even
though there are federal protections for
employees right if I go and I work for
someone and they called me you know
speak wet back or whatever it is right
they're trying to be racist towards me
call me names or you know misgender me
or whatever it is right
um
there's a you know I could I could
honestly see again obviously having
Federal Protections in place from
employees
um so that discrimination doesn't happen
but I wouldn't put past
someone of the Republican party to say
okay we've passed this bill
for people who are employed as teachers
to discriminate against children mind
you they work for the government right
public teachers work for the government
right The Next Step would be in my
workplace my place of employment my boss
can say derogatory races bigoted hateful
xenophobic whatever things they might do
right and typically be like oh okay I've
got a case against discrimination
because they I had to quit or they may
feel like [__] or whatever it is right
but based on the way that they treated
me and I wouldn't be surprised if we had
Republicans are like great we've now
established this in the classroom as
precedent and now we're going to use
that as a building block to then push on
to the workplace so now anywhere you
work you can say the n-word or you can
say anything else that's bigoted or
racist or transphobic or whatever it
might be and get away with and be like
well that's your free freedom of speech
they could say that they can totally say
that
but you can't you can't say those things
you can't treat people like that that's
not how we're that's how we're meant to
be Republicans want it to be a [__]
free-for-all hellscape where they can
call anyone anything they want they want
people to be their property they want to
be able to take what they want say what
they want it is disgusting but just know
that just like when we talked about
before Roe v Wade people like oh they're
not going to come after all these other
things no it's a building block it is it
is they're pushing the envelope and
saying what can we do next what can we
take away next and the next thing after
uh teachers being able to say this in
the classroom to [__] minors to
children
is the idea that an employer can say
this to an employee and not get [__]
fired or sued for it that's what they
want to do that's what they want to have
and it's it's disgusting it's gross here
is another exchange during this debate
of this uh bill this guy this car or
this state representative Tennessee
Cochran you know what I think is you
know what I think his pronouns are Gabe
in the closet that's what I think his uh
his pronouns are probably are you know
what I mean I'm just saying hey you
wanna you wanna [__] talk about
pronouns Cochrane I think your pronouns
are in the closet buddy
um so let's let's watch this exchange uh
here Hospital 1269 allows a teacher to
refer to a student by pronouns based on
the students verse sex without fear of
adverse disciplinary or legal action
this bill is ridiculous this bill
emboldens teachers the ones we entrust
to guide our children to air their
biases openly to deny our children their
true selves to publicly misgender them
it puts a Target on their backs they
will be bullied taunted and shamed
instead of an education these children
will be gifted anxiety depression and
adjustment disorder that is exactly what
these Republicans want what she's
describing what she's describing is
that's not a glitch of this bill it is
the feature it is the intent I just want
to point that out now she's pointing it
out but this is the intent of the bill
it's not that this is the side effect
this is what they intend to do is to
shame people eradicate them eradicate
them listen tell me one positive thing
but any of these bills is accomplishing
we are not stupid none of us believe
this is about protecting children you
have over 20 bills on the docket right
now targeting this community stop lying
this is about intolerance for an entire
group of humans persecuting a group of
people is going to land you on the wrong
side of History your legacy will be one
of embarrassment you want this community
to Fade Into Darkness but you aren't
going to stop hearing from me from my
friends until this stops
school is supposed to be somewhere safe
a teacher should be someone you can
trust to be there for you to help you
this will surely have a negative impact
not just on those students but also the
ones who witness it who will also fear
their teachers and be taught how to hate
in the classroom this legislature is
showing how little they care about
children and the future of Tennessee and
it is Despicable I'm not very religious
but since I've begun coming to your
hearings I've started to pray for all of
you
I have started to pray for all you guys
I mean this is coming from the party
that says you know we want to save the
children save the kids you know and also
the fact that look
the state of America right now is at any
place whether it's a church a grocery
store or a school is not safe we live in
an environment in a society where guns
uh outnumber people right uh where where
where people can get access to guns and
take out their their anger and their
frustration on other people who who are
not nice for whatever reason right
so schools kids have to go to schools
with backpacks with bulletproof
backpacks with the fear of not knowing
whether they're going to see the next
the next morning right parents not
knowing if their kids gonna make it home
from school because at any point any
crazy person can show up and [__]
shoot the place up so in addition to
that you're now gonna say that these
kids who already are born into a
generation that's [__] on edge and
has anxiety over whether or not they're
going to live to see the end of the day
and go to recess right or go home and
have snacks and watch [__] cartoons
or whatever it might be not only that
but now you're saying when you're in the
classroom not even the teacher is your
friend not even the teacher will protect
you not even the teacher will look out
for your well-being and care because
what they're going to say is I don't
like that person because of their skin I
don't like that person because
they don't identify or they don't look
the way that they're supposed to look or
whatever it might be you can say I'm
going to attack and I'm gonna bully you
and I'm gonna create
a a culture of fear and hate inside of
this place that's supposed to Foster
learning and education instead you're
now teaching his kids as they said or
not teaching them but you're now you're
now treating them poorly where they're
you know separate years down like these
traumatic events be like now they have
depression or anxiety or or uh they have
the inability to to express themselves
in a social environment because they
can't trust people right so not only do
kids have to go to school with the fear
of being shot but now they have to go to
school fearing that their teacher is
going to make fun of them because of who
they are
and that's what Republicans want they
want any any excuse to treat anyone
shitty and not have the consequences to
get them in trouble because that's what
it is right I mean that's what they want
they want to prevent the ability to be
called out and have consequences for
their yeah right they they want to be
able to be bigots and not have any
consequence for it let's wrap this up
running out of time and spend two hours
already it's like five minutes but it's
been two hours really it is let's listen
I don't know what could incentive iPhone
makers to harm children but those
supporting the many bills passing your
desk I hope you gain empathy and a
willingness to learn about your
constituents I grew up hoping someone
would stop my bullies from hurting me so
I'm hoping to stop the bullies I see
from hurting my friends please vote no
and put children's sanity before
Prejudice no one can learn in a school
from someone they feel disrespected by
or feel fearful of the vast majority of
LGBT students in Tennessee regularly
hear homophobic and transphobic remark
not only from their students but from
their teachers this bill legally
protects this kind of discrimination
from a local librarian students have a
hard time getting teachers to respect
them and their pronouns as it is the
last thing we need is the government
mandating disrespect House Bill 1269 all
those in favor of moving into finance
committee and indicator saying aye
opposed name did I have it moves out to
finance oh yeah we're going to the
finance committee now the here's the
people who release this video Tennessee
holler
um you you must you must go follow
Tennessee holler across platforms
um though they're bringing you all the
news out of Tennessee from from these
despicable bills that they're trying to
pass how Tennessee is laying the
groundwork
um to out Florida Florida here and to
take away the consent of your children
I've been saying it since last summer
this is what they're doing and they're
doing it systematically this is just
this is just not about transgender
children this is about Joe this is about
a child who desires for them someone to
call them they them yeah right they may
not even be transgender just they want
to be called they them and they could
call them anything they want as Justin
Jones the Tennessee State Rep said what
would happen what would happen when this
bill protected teacher and if they
called me the end word um so despicable
[__] coming out of Tennessee we won't
stop talking about it here uh we're
gonna keep um featuring it and showing
it to you as it comes in because I think
some of it gets swept underneath the rug
as far as how Despicable and what these
people are trying to do to your consent
for your children
um so you need to come here every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube
Twitter and twitch hit that subscribe
button it's free [__] free why
wouldn't you watch this show it's free
for two full hours or two hours and
seven or eight minutes something like
that
um it also follow us on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod and download every single
episode for free 99 then cost you a
thing on Apple Spotify Google it's like
theft over there Gabe Sanchez yeah steal
it swipe steal it you know what else you
can steal Jeff bezos's money if you have
an Amazon Prime account Go download
twitch log in to your Twitch account
with your Amazon Prime account and you
can actually give us one free
subscription Jeff Bezos gives us money
for you to sign in with your Prime
account so go do that yeah that's right
you can steal his money it is this swipe
that wave that wave was for uh for Chris
person he said Give me the give me the
wave oh he wants those tiny hands if
you're still on Facebook if you got a
Facebook account out there don't forget
to follow us there at Tony Michaels at
the Tony Michaels you can go to the Tony
michaels.com you find all the links
there even to the patreon we had a great
Sunday rant yesterday and I had a great
q a on Saturday and I know Gabe Sanchez
is doing a lot of stuff on his patreon
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez so go to
patreon.com look up me and Gabe over
there see what's going on over on the
extra content but in this show will
always be free it's gonna be free
absolutely free
um Everybody same time same place
tomorrow Surf's Up [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events in political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon